geht seine ablösung wenn ihm fern sie
irgendwie bericht kommt über waldbrände
oder so und ostern es brennt ein gebiet
in der größe von
900.000 fußballfeldern ich komme da ich
gar nichts darunter vorstellen
ich denke das ist wahrscheinlich viel
oder aber aber wie groß genau ich weiß
es nicht ich meine fußball weiß nicht
wie groß ein fußballfeld ist ich komme
da nichts darunter vorstellen
dass wir große puzzle ist das was ich
machen dürfen was ja ganz genau wie
großer briefmarken ist und wenn stores
das brennt ein gebiet das ist so groß
wie
900.000 drei jahren milliarden billionen
millionen
briefmarken dann wissen sie genau wie
groß das gebiet ist denkt man schon mal
es kann man alles so einfach sein